today we're making our own table tennis
racquets with one 100 and one thousand
dollar budgets and have four challenges
to decide whose racket is the best will
money make a difference let's find out
okay it's time to decide who gets which
budget so each balloon has a certain
amount of money and when it explodes
we'll find out how much is in it
[Applause]
oh
you got yourself 100 euros i'm happy
with that budget
[Music]
1000 euros
i have no idea what i'm gonna do with
one in europe i think it's time to go
build our rackets okay so i got 1 000
euros to spend on my racket so obviously
we're gonna get some diamonds i'm
looking for diamonds for a ping-pong
racket oh that's that sounds cool
this is 90 000.
let's have a look at these smaller ones
perfect
maybe if i get a lot of these small
diamonds an additional rule to building
the racket is that you're not allowed to
use any real table tennis products i
wonder how opto is doing with this one
euro i found a dress some cardboard oh
this is looking interesting hardwood
floor is there something i could do with
this still would need to find some kind
of rubber my budget 100 euros i did some
plans my challenge is gonna be like you
have to do the maximum amount of ball
bounces with the racket bottom so
obviously i have to come up with a
racket that has a wide bottom so let's
head inside this is probably a bit too
wide the next step would be to find the
kind of like this shaft not really into
that one
no this is the coolest handle that you
have ever seen on a table tennis racket
i'm gonna have some jedi powers against
me kind of maybe
this shopping center looks expensive the
racket has to be gold this could be the
perfect blade it's not only a cake
server it's a fine cake serve i'm
looking for golden sheep on a table
tennis racquet
it's not real gold unfortunately because
they didn't have it but it's going to be
the most beautiful racket and that's why
my challenge is going to be a beauty
contest so we're gonna let you guys vote
who has the prettiest racket and
obviously otto and emel's ugly cheap
rackets won't stand a chance we're gonna
go and look for a blacksmith we can do a
lot of stuff with this you can even see
through it which is pretty cool we need
some rubber for the for the racket this
is the one that we're looking for
anti-slip mat let's take this one and
head towards the working space my
challenge is going to be
to catch a ball that is being hit
straight at you so
if this would be my handle then i would
put this like somewhere here
could i even put another butt there
so i have this rubber mat i'm gonna put
a piece of it on the bottom the new
sensor bracket going live on finity dot
store maybe
this is gonna be the blade and this is
gonna be the robbers is it gonna be a
good racket what do you think of course
it's going to be a great record
this is one of the perks of winning the
1000 euro budget you don't have to build
it yourself i have to be pretty careful
when when i'm playing with that
i'm going to cut two parts of this and
then we put them together and it's going
to be something magical
one out of two
we're going to round the edges a bit
oh that's so satisfying we need still a
few more screws so let's not screw this
up this is gonna look so nice
back to the headquarters and now it's
time to reveal the rackets i'll go get
my records let's see what what the
sensei has brought and this
is my brackets that's a chair it's a
table tennis racket can't you see it
looks like
from robo wars or something
very good engineering super solid like
how did you spend your budget one euro
i still have my whole budget to use it
looks like you've spent zero euros on
this yeah thank you
are you guys ready for the next one the
100 budget yes we're ready for it let's
go let's go
oh my god
what is that
he's really a lightsaber
is this absolutely necessary the famous
challenge is like bounce with the bottom
of the racquet
it's looking good i have to say the
lightsaber part that was 12 euros
polycarbonate material this is 60 euros
the rubber that was like seven euros
total budget like 80 euros okay guys are
you ready for my the world's most
expensive table tennis racket what is it
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's the infinity gold racquet wow
that's impressive real real diamonds
really yeah
you can barely see them it's the shape
of a diamond if you turn it around okay
so let's break down the costs cake
cutter 40 euros surface plate 70 euros
shaping and assembling everything 150
diamonds
550 and engravements 50. the rest me and
the racket decided to treat ourselves
how did you treat the racket
[Music]
let's do the challenges
you guessed it's absolutely right it
just found i'm not feeling too confident
about this one try
oh oh i think i think it was three
i'll use this one
that's zero zero
i was trying this after i made this and
it's actually very difficult
no don't
no no no no i wasn't that against the
rule was it no
there we go yeah that's enough no need
to call we know you have the best racket
bottom out of all three i'll take the
lead so let's move on to my challenge a
ball catch are you gonna smash it at me
yeah catch it without any bounces
without any bounces ready
[Applause]
this is impossible
maybe now you see what that part of my
record is for i feel scammed i feel
absolutely
cheated good luck emil ready yeah i'm
ready i'm ready
[Applause]
let's see if you can do better
that's it
i have one point mikka is still at zero
but maybe the next challenge is yours we
are gonna have a beauty contest oh
i like the idea we made an instagram
poll for you guys to vote for the most
beautiful racket and at the end of the
episode we will see which one you chose
as the prettiest one make sure to watch
until the end of the video to see the
results of the poll let's see your
challenge so you all have your own half
of a table and who gets three points
first wins match the three points on a
triangle table quite simple
the golden racket to the win
you have to have the light effect
i got it
oh no it's really fast lightsaber is
coming into play
second point
chance to win the game
yes
results are in will money count
with eighteen percent eighteen percent
percentage
actually is
contestant a
auto
[Applause]
against diamond gold the most beautiful
racket
ever made by the pongfinity guys the
winner of the
whole tournament
is
with forty
one
percent it's a thai game
yeah you're kidding me no
forty one forty one eighteen that
is equally amazing yeah this was so much
fun if you enjoyed this video make sure
to subscribe